remember I said this is double barrel
question right locate the station points
and then determine their nature right
locate you'd already been doing this
right if I gave you a function let's do
this right now example okay we're just
going to choose this example because
it's it's so easy and you can do it
without thinking if I said to you excuse
me
locate the station on your points and
did to them in their nature here's the
way I would do it the stationary point
by definition is where F - the
derivative is zero does that make sense
so first I'd better get F - what is it -
okay good I would say my next line for
stationary points and I'm gonna let you
use the the abbreviation day after doing
that thanks for a while at least in the
mathematics you guys humility SP doesn't
really ever stand for anything so
stationary points if X 0 we're talking
about the importance of these
intermediate lines like a wine like this
don't just jump straight to the next
thing I highly discourage that ie 2x
plus 5 that's F dash equal zero and of
course you're getting the answer you
expect because you know where the roots
are they get to negative 3 and that's a
snap back between them okay
I found an x coordinate but a point has
two coordinates so what am I gonna do
now what that value is
right so now I've got an X and I have
its corresponding coordinate I would say
therefore there's a stationary pen right
now I have not determined its nature yet
excuse me
to determine the nature what you really
want to pay attention to is always green
business right that's why I'm trying to
draw your attention to it in what way
does the gradient change on either side
right is it going from negative to
positive or positive to negative or is
it sign staying
same on both sides okay so we're going
to draw up and there are other methods
you'll learn to do this later on but for
now we're going to draw up a table of
values for our green derivative right
like so now remember I'm trying to see
what happens before what happens after
because that's really what's going on if
I don't have a picture if I knew it what
negatives you were positive I could say
it's a minimum if I knew it went
positive here and negative I know it's a
maximum okay so I want to pick well I
know what's going to happen in the two
and a half when they do not I don't know
what the grating is that's fine then I
just want to pick a point on the left
and a point on the right okay now up
all right some principles for how you
choose this in a second but for now I
think these numbers will suffice
okay let's test it and then let's talk
about how you choose these numbers
because I just got to pull them out of
random right uh here is f dash right so
what's F dash of negative three minus
six plus five f dash of negative 2 is
minus 4 plus 5 which is positive one
okay so now when I look at this this is
literally what I do right I say look my
gradient transitions from negative to
zero to positive right negative means
I'm decreasing zero remains this a
stationary point and then positive means
I'm going up what does that shape look
like that's a minimum is it the middle
because of course it's just this
parabola right so I would say off the
basis of this table therefore negative
two and a half maybe in the portal is a
minimum turning point that's the kind of
turning point
okay question I've seen people do like
this stuff with Justin like you know
they sub in like Korean - you're a
detective X and they realize this like a
negative then they just put a negative
in the box and they realize that yeah
well - Jerry is a positive plus in the
books would you prefer for us to write a
value in them or would you prefer to
write like a symbol that's a great
question okay just in case you are not
quite following with what we're talking
about but this is what he means people
say okay negative two and a half I know
because I found the station your quick
side note that is that's fine okay and
then they say oh okay
you know you've got a really simple
derivative here frequently this
derivative is not nearly as simple and
it's like some real effort to actually
work out what those values are but when
you start putting in numbers you're like
oh oh it's it's it's clearly going to be
negative and they do this right and then
they have a look at the other one and
it's a bit of a mess but they've gone
far enough either with a calculator or
an apron that they say yeah it's
positive okay so sometimes people do
this and you should never ever ever do
this okay now let's just talk about life
for a second I know why people do it
I told you the reason why it's because
computing this is sometimes it's
actually work okay well surprise
surprise before waiting right now why is
this a problem okay the reason why is
because frequently you see how I said we
can't station points determine their
nature okay um in order to work out
what's really going on questions
frequently already knew what the nature
of the station could be okay and I'll
talk about optimization I want a bigger
one
I want a smaller one okay so you kind of
are expecting you know I might know like
even before I've even touched the
question
I'm expecting a minimum right and you
can just read that off the question the
question might even say locate the
stationary points and prove that blah
blah blah is a minimum turning point
okay so the question already tells you
this is what's coming right now by doing
this what have I demonstrated what
understanding if I demonstrate
and the answer is nothing like I've
showed I could read the question but I
haven't actually been able to work with
it
okay as a result this number and this
number are critically important it has
to be a number okay and that is like the
fastest way to lose one mark off of your
derivative yeah yeah so I think if we
were to do like negative zero positive
that's that's fair game
that's fake I will tell you the reason
why most people do those lines for a
couple of reasons number one it helps
you remember it helps you ground
yourself in the fact that what is
negative meaning it oh yeah it's going
down it's decreasing right so it touches
you back to there's geometric meaning
here which is good right and then once
you see that oh it's obvious right if
you saw something else like say it's
positive then it's zero and then it's
positive again like the picture itself
tells you what you're looking at
it's an enormous ly helpful tool I think
this is fun I can write this and ice
like I can't help but see this when I
see that but at least when I started
this was really useful to me so it's off
but the most important part is the
numbers